it looks familiar from the outside but
the technology has changed a lot ciate
30 beats a series a makeover they've
amped up the compact cars electronics
and reworked its engine the basic
gasoline model now sports a 1-liter
3-cylinder engine the naturally
aspirated version comes with 75
horsepower while the Eco TSI turbo
alternative boasts up to 110 and Germany
prices for the Spanish car range from
11900 9220 1940 euros this Michael I
know Dyson offer our car tester says the
new Ibiza has a lot to offer
particularly on the inside the exterior
makeover is rather subtle but there is a
choice of colors for the decorative
strips around the grill the mirror caps
and the rims moons father
it's what's on the inside that counts
but tastes differ so say hot lets
customers make the e beats as newly
designed interior match their gusto
oh I know takes a look at the new he
beats his inside and points out some
changes its steering wheel is exactly
the same as in the big early on he
center display between the speedometer
and rev counter showing useful
information got bigger the navigation
system now also comes in 6.5 inches a
special feature drivers can connect
their smartphone to the ibiza within
seconds maybe it's the köppen changes on
the outside are less obvious customers
still love the e beaches modern exterior
design so say I only tweaked it a little
the compact car got new headlamps with
LED daytime running lights and new 16 or
17 inch alloy wheels with touches of
color the trunk holds 292 liters or even
938 leaders once the seatbacks are
flipped in knowing cid bitsa see a
product manager torsten becker points
out a function called full link drivers
can use it to hook up their apple or
android devices to the Ibiza sounds
complicated just imagine a laptop being
connected to a projector it's the same
principle and I know Stella poyet ones
OS Tasya optifine tourists NASA's
smartphone what's the weather like in
Berlin is he touching the reply it's not
great today it's raining and the lowest
temperature is 7 degrees
a brand new generation of gasoline and
diesel engines power the Ibiza our test
car is equipped with a 1.2 liter TSI
engine which consumes an average of 4.9
litres in 100 kilometers according to
see at the top speed is 184 km/h
the Ibiza got a more fine-tuned steering
and softer suspension to make its
handling mimic the bigger leone's d
beats a style we drove for our test
costs fifteen thousand nine hundred
ninety euros in Germany early next year
the more powerful top-of-the-range cupra
will complete the product range it will
come with a 1.8 liter 192 horsepower
turbo gasoline engine
10 or even my notes verdict the beats a
makeover convinced him especially the
reworked chassis he says it's fun to
crunch the gears his tip is the one
liter version sporting three cylinders
and 110 horsepower because it has a top
speed of 200 km/h with low fuel
consumption